so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect yo what's up guys i am thomas
dobaziola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast i'm
with my co-host marty o'neil what's up
folks what up guys today today's uh if
you see the smile i'm excited because
this is one of the few times i can say
and he's from merced
you can't ever say that stuff guys this
is gb what do you want to be what do you
go by gb is fine gb
all right gb this uh artist out of
merced bro out of merced california
which makes me so happy it makes it just
like it's wild good i'm so happy we can
do this i know right we have a all right
hold on
we'll get into that
so right now you would just how old did
you say you were i'm 29 how long you
doing music for three years
what the [ __ ] wait hold on so i've been
doing music since i was a kid like
[ __ ] with it okay that's what i meant
but actually taking as serious as a
career like it's trying to persuade you
it's been three years yet
you know three years usually like 10
years you start seeing something there's
a lot of times in my world
right now yeah he's from i don't know if
you know about mark murray's from the
east coast he did a lot of music back
then
and well he's doing more music now but
it's just it's awesome to see someone
like you started how it's like a
basketball player when you start playing
today
yeah well the thing was that i was
always either on probation or parole
so like the the the
you know their guidelines are pretty
strict when it comes down to
any type of music coming from uh an
alleged gang banger right you know what
i'm saying anything i say is considered
gang related
so therefore they use that as a
violation oh sure i always refrain from
it
i'm saying so they can use your lyrics
yeah they'll be like you know it's gang
related you're making gang related music
to benefit uh your gang i didn't know
and uh they used that as you know as an
excuse to violate you so i was like i'm
not trying to do no time for a song you
know i was like i'd rather just wait
and basically i was i got out of prison
this last time when i was 25.
uh i got off probation when i was 26
and immediately after i got released i
just started so now i'm 29.
wow man
i didn't know any of this backstory so
yeah before we get into that are you are
you born and raised in merced born to
raise merced mercedes full-blown
all right where'd you grow up at i grew
up all around merced exactly for me i
was born uh
in in on 12th street that's what i never
remember yeah it was a mercy hospital on
13th yeah it's closed down now yeah yeah
oh it actually reopened they did reopen
yeah it reopened because it used to be a
armageddon town
i i think it's something that had to
that has to do with the county or
probation or some [ __ ] like that i see a
lot of tweakers out there so maybe it's
like a like a methadone clinic too or
something
it might be man i see a lot of tweakers
out there i haven't had a reason to go
yet but just on the freeway i look yeah
and uh
but yeah i've been moving all around you
feel me i'm very familiar with elmer
said
uh
especially like uh the west the west
side
and uh
mainly like around like the merced high
area
okay okay i'm saying what middle school
like elementaries you're going to my mom
my mom purchased that she
after moving around like bouncing around
home to home and [ __ ] like that she
ended up saving up for a little down
payment for a house uh over in in that
area
and uh
that kind of made me uh go to
uh chenoweth
right there i used to live across the
street from china okay yeah and
we weren't broke anymore yeah middle
school middle school uh the district it
was a crook shanks district
and then uh merc said hi i bounced
around from like merced high
to like um
uh yosemite east campus independent
studies did you ever go to uh valley
nah that's why i chose to be on
independent study okay i was smart
enough to know like
everybody wanted to go to valley because
they wanted to go yeah it was like
you feel me around my circle it was like
you were you were the cool you were that
guy if you're not valley i was like you
were waiting
yeah
yeah like you you you went all the gang
members yeah my brother went with the
homies yeah but i was you know i already
knew i was like once i go to valley like
i'm it's over it's over like i'm full
i'm going you know i was smart enough to
know that much so i was like i'll just
go to independent studies
and uh the majority of that time i was
on the bracelet anyways on house arrest
as a minor
so i could only really go to school to
turn in my homework
damn i know about these kids man
yeah so that's how i spent like you feel
me uh some of them but it kind of gets
you out of trouble at that point you
know if you went to valley you would you
would have got in so much more trouble
yeah even then it was hard as [ __ ] not
to cut the bracelet off either oh you
were that kid what were you doing what
were you doing that got you in trouble
because i'm from there too i already
know but for the audience i think that
time that i got on the bracelet
uh you know how they have the the the
buy list i don't know if they still do
to keep it 100 but
back then they had violence at uh like
the mexican dances
where they bring mexican artists at the
fairgrounds every sunday
so i went there on sunday
and one of my buddies at
at um
that i went with he was a
couple years older than me at the time
he had the idea you know
the buy size they were all fat chains
and
iced out watches and all this stuff you
know
so he got the idea like we gotta rob one
of these dudes i'm saying
so uh
you know
[ __ ] went down and
that's how that's how i ended up on the
bracelet that time damn you guys got
caught there doing it
you know that fool probably sucked one
of you guys those fools don't play
around with the boots uh yeah i mean it
was a wild night
yeah
i heard about these [ __ ] fairgrounds
too we've talked about it yeah ever said
it um don't go to the fair
that's all i got to say yeah even even
like the fair guy i try to refrain from
being in public in general because
it's just you know what i mean i like to
be about the way tuck
do you think yeah just
point a to point b you feel me
if any about you know
my family you're getting no no no money
in my pockets and it
it's it's not 19. you ain't trying to go
to the fair and chill with your homies
like yeah that's merced bro why stay
outside why be out there yeah
and although it's a small town for those
who don't know
they're like oh you know there ain't
[ __ ] going on merced there ain't nothing
like it's it's it's a
it's it's a high crime rate area for so
like where we're from like
[ __ ] people get killed yeah somebody got
shot yesterday on 12th street i heard
you hear me
so 12th and 10th i don't know what it is
about that area i don't know who's
renting i don't know what landlord is
that but yo this was one gang bring his
ass in here
10th and 12th street's wild bro
yeah the whole west goes crazy yeah yeah
hotel in general you never know what's
going to happen where yeah but like you
said if you stay out you stay out of
people's way do your own thing well one
thing i noticed about merced is like
we're like 10 years back
like if la these these dudes are doing
some other [ __ ]
they're still tripping on ships 10 years
ago like when i moved here i was like
i'm cool i can wear this blue like yeah
if we know where you're at like
we don't care about that like what i
ain't going to wear no that's why i'll
drive my car to my shed no more it's
blue as hell
hell no dude you you know what i mean
like i like my sweater when you sleep
that's different though
when you walked in with this one went
you're in l.a oh damn ballsy but then
again you shouldn't have to think that
way you should be able to wear what you
want yeah like yeah
it ain't like i'm feeling my mind you're
tripping no i could say there's nothing
like i'm right i'm i'm here for business
i'm not really too like you said you're
in the studio last night in stockton
yeah drove straight here going straight
back to frisco first go after this for a
music video
nice look at this
it's just 24 hours man yeah no cap and
then after that it's it's back to work
you know it's back to another music
video tomorrow
and then uh
catch a flight to hawaii friday
it's for vacation but i like to take
advantage of it so i got a video shoot
lined up out there too
um and just trying to you know
be consistent like like of course like
you said what we were saying earlier
like
after doing this you know for three
years straight
you know i'm here today
so if i keep doing this for another
three years straight oh yeah who knows
where the [ __ ] i could be i'm saying so
of course just
like i've said before in previous
interviews
my entire music career has been a trial
and error for me i try somehow if it
doesn't work out
find a different route fit me until
some gives
but uh
i i have no clue what i'm doing up to
this point still
i mean as far as being an artist though
like if you had to describe your the
theme of your music what it's about what
you're trying to get across
well it started off the
i mainly started rapping about
the life in merced for somebody like
myself
i'm saying uh
we you know a lot of similar stuff goes
down and merced that it does in other
bigger cities just not in that amount
you know what i mean
uh you know we got a population of maybe
86 000 or something
and let's say we average like i don't
know 25 murders a year
it's obviously not going to compare to
like 150 like chicago or 200 because
we're small
but
it's a small town that nobody's heard of
in the central valley
uh a lot goes on but not a lot you know
to do at the same time
so
growing up i was like man ain't nobody
from here really talking about what we
what we're experiencing what we're
living through here you know
so
that's how i started i was like let me
just rap about what happens here what we
live through what we see
what we go through
and uh you know people just felt it they
they reacted well to it and uh
now you know that i got a cool solid fan
base
i'm able to venture off onto different
topics with my music
but still somehow try to
come back and and connect with what
initially started which is just just our
life
just you know daily struggles uh
[ __ ] you you you're more than likely to
see in the hood and
and [ __ ] like that
yeah real quick one thing i've been
noticing on your instagram
i never seen anybody
i guess
what would you say like back up the city
so much bro everything you do i see it's
in merced you're doing the well like i
told you earlier before we started
mcnamara park i used to i used to do
football practice my grandma owns the
apartment touching that i grew up there
that's where he does a lot of the the i
see you guys doing like pop-ups and
clothing pop so what's tell us more
about that for everyone out there in the
valley stuff happens you just gotta look
right
uh well i hear a lot of people say he
number says boring there ain't [ __ ] to
do here
uh i mean it's it's it's only boring
like i think only boring people are
boring you know what i mean
we like like i was telling you
you either got it like okay yeah
mercedes boring then he should do
whatever so
make something happen you feel me give
give the people something to do give the
people something to look forward to
um or or or just get out just move
somewhere else you feel me if you hate
it that bad yeah some people are ashamed
some people do move
and claim another town or city
you know they'll they'll they'll put
like i'm from fresno like bro you lived
in merced your whole [ __ ] life
or i'm from l.a now or san diego
wherever the [ __ ] they moved to
oh
it looks like these joints up my bad oh
yeah it's all good
and uh
me personally i've always been uh
you know i'm i'm proud of where i came
from you know what i'm saying of course
so
i just i ain't got no shame in it at all
so
i'm one of those people that have been
inspired by people like nipsey hustle
and stuff like that that
rather invest and contribute to their
community you feel me in a positive way
so
that's where all these giveaways started
the first one actually
i was at buy right right there on 11th
and and uh mlk which is a chevron now
oh no way yes chevron it's been a
chevron for a couple years now i haven't
been there so long it's still buy right
slash chevron you feel me they got the
sign on the window oh okay that's like
the biggest
yeah
so
what's it gonna say you're saying the
you said the first one started off by
right yeah so
it was
my boy's the owner of it so
i knew he was working on like new year's
eve he's like a workaholic too he go his
name's t shout out to you by the way
and i think i took him some like a plate
of food for like i think it was
christmas
christmas eve i think it was probably
like 11 p.m
and i knew he was at the store because
you know they're like you know i don't
know if they don't celebrate her he just
had to work the show
but i was like he had the story for me
while you know we're with our family
so i took him a plate of food
of mexican food or whatever we had or i
don't know
and uh
he's like you know good looking it's
like 11 11 30 p.m i was alright man i
got to go so i went outside when i
walked outside to go back to the car i
seen a homeless person
uh just chilling you know like sitting
down so in my head i'm like the streets
are dead as [ __ ] he knows what day it is
he knows his christmas eve i'm saying i
don't know what he did to get in that
position but i had like a heartfelt
moment so i was like bro i gotta just
start giving back to the to the
community
so the first one uh after that was uh
it was like a thanksgiving giveaway we
gave like care packages out of food to
the homeless that's what i saw then it
was like a christmas giveaway giveaway
uh
uh
we'd see
bikes and skateboards and scooters to
the kids for christmas
uh
we do back to school giveaways
we buy vendors out like the paleteros
about how much you want for your whole
car
i'll be like you know 800 or some or a
thousand whatever here
i'm gonna call the whole hood to come
and get what they want because we
basically bought everything on your car
they're like that's cool we probably
paid their rent or something you know
so they'll come and we're kind of known
for that now like hey these dudes
there's always giving back that's
positive what i'm saying
so that's that's just how they come
about and then
obviously with with the music career
kind of blowing up i'm able to you know
network with other artists
and uh
you know rather than
you know let's have a pop-up out here
let's pull it i'll be like let's have a
pop-up in this in the hood at mac park
where everybody in the hood listens to
your music and supports your clothing
brand and all that [ __ ] and that's how
we we just bring it all to the hood you
know what i mean and it's just
i love to see you look at it you know
what i'm saying i saw boost and tense
there's people chilling
like this it gets crazy this is more sad
bro like no one's ever made it fun
outside yeah
if it's that it's like yo who's here oh
[ __ ] these fools are here we should
probably go
yeah
it's not that vibe i mean at least what
i saw
i saw you guys
just giving back to people and i really
appreciate that
yeah that's how you build an
organization fan base that lasts over
time
yeah exactly
uh it's just it all happens kind of
organically
like uh one of my nephews what what's
high school did you go to say hi mm-hmm
i don't know a year you graduated but
you remember mr schaefer of course he's
a principal he was a principal at the
time
well i know emily i used to be in the
office a lot
i used to be in trouble a lot yeah yeah
i know him so
i think if it correct me if i if i'm
wrong but every grade has a different
principle
so like freshman's had to go to school
enough to know that's intense oh i
didn't know that man maybe because i was
in the office so much
i didn't know that that existed if
you know if i'm not mistaken that's how
it was
so
and a lot of after a while they would
just be like you know just chill till
that period because i get kicked out of
class and you're cordial and polite with
them i guarantee it and they're like yo
i [ __ ] with this kid yeah so yeah it's
crazy because my little nephew asked me
to go to uh an assembly so you got like
a newsletter oh you go sorry you got one
right next to my bed and there's a marty
can you bring up the ashtray
okay and uh
he asked me to take him to an assembly
so i took him and that's the first
person i've seen was mr schaefer i guess
he uh
i guess he's like a vice principal i
think right there
and it's a lot he looks a lot uh you
know older than what he looked like
because i think i don't know if he was
coaching football or something back then
but uh
that's a long time or that my first name
in a minute
and uh
and what he said he was like oh you know
school senior i i you know
i [ __ ] with your music and what you're
doing with the community but not in in
other words you feel me he didn't cuss
or nothing like that
yeah guaranteed bishop was like i have
[ __ ] with you
that new [ __ ] you're putting up
[ __ ] fire
but anyways assembly's taking place or
whatever and then i see like six
uh
distinguished honor roll students
and i never been the type to to judge a
person by
you know his looks or what he's wearing
at all you for me
because i'm humble enough to know that
[ __ ] like but i was broke as [ __ ] you
know
you know hand-me-downs and all that [ __ ]
before so i don't judge but
you know i i was like
like i say oh with those six or six on
the rose you know what i'm saying uh it
looked like they could use a new pair of
shoes you feel me and i was in the
middle of opening a sneaker shop at the
time
so i i went to school to that school the
next day
and i told them if i could you know
give them a a new pair of
nike jordan like retro
and he's like you know that'd be dope so
like
little [ __ ] like that it kind of
encourages it's huge bro to be like oh
you'll never forget that in the morning
i mean like
and we're gonna keep doing it you know
we've done that [ __ ] with different
schools dancing makes me feel like i
ain't doing enough
damn oh my god
i love this dude that's [ __ ] amazing
because go back to school and drop
something i love that that's what you do
when you've made it so it's like by
doing that you're already acting as if
like love that i love the attitude of
not sitting around and waiting for like
a big record deal like i'm
i'm i'm waiting for a big pop and then
it's going to happen you're like and
it's it's love bro like
it's it's it's crazy it's come to the
time and it's and it's all [ __ ] that you
feel like you've been there at some
point in time so you feel it
like i i'll [ __ ] around and pick up a
homeless dude take them to the store
like you know like the liquor store or
something
get whatever you want you know
uh dropping back just doing what you can
bro i mean like on your daily [ __ ]
simple [ __ ] you feel me like i don't
think i like that no it doesn't tell you
and those kids it was like a couple
hundred bucks for these shoes those
fools are gonna be like yo i did good in
school this folk gave me some shoes yeah
look at this video this is the guy like
they're never gonna forget that
you know what i'm saying especially in a
town like that we didn't have [ __ ] like
that
especially the place like that dude yeah
you looked at the fools that made the
most money that's really what it was for
me like oh he he got a car damn all
right what'd you sell
yeah yeah yeah like my little my other
little brother martin luther you wanted
to be like them like the hustlers
it wasn't so much that cause like
just
from me like growing up my mom if i ever
came home with you my mom like i'm a
punch in your [ __ ] mouth and don't
ever hang out with that kid again like
cause my mom told me any [ __ ]
my dad was trying to do that nor daniel
[ __ ] when i was a kid he'd come over
with a slick chopped hair
red jeans and [ __ ] tried to get me to
wear red like dad my favorite color is
blue like you know where you live
well then i guess i'll wear black my
whole life
you're right so like my whole life i
mean i said second street uh right by
the dead end park yeah the apartment
that's right that was my apartment right
there the next one over the little
apartment's on second yeah no second so
even though my bus stops right there
exactly i had to walk around because my
mom wouldn't let me walk through the
park because she's just like you know
what the [ __ ] goes on in this park
that's when the m.o.d fools were
shooting everybody the asian dudes who
were kids yeah when you were a kid yeah
when i was a kid so my mom would let me
go over there and um it's a difference
though because look
look what you're doing compared to
somebody that's working at the [ __ ]
mall doing some [ __ ] probably not doing
giving back at all yeah there's a give
and take like you said you can't just
judge somebody by the way yeah we
started doing that [ __ ] when we were
still like working on the fives type
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
were you working before you started
doing this
right before i started rapping i i was
working at you might not even heard of
this place because i think it
i think it came to the to the united
states a company from mexico that came
to united states like
2013 if i'm not mistaken
they first came as with the company roto
plus
they carried on up until i quit type 2
what was it what is that
oh we made a
plastic like irrigation tanks
yeah so you work with flame you work
under the heat type [ __ ] it's it's in a
warehouse but it's hot as [ __ ] that's in
merced and we're set over by uh
behind walmart going towards beechwood
yeah about 84 lumber used to be exactly
yeah right on the same road yeah so
i mean i already knew since i paroled
this last time i already knew what i
want to do i was like bro i want to make
music you know i'm saying
so
i was working there
and that's where i was working check the
check
like you for me i wasn't getting paid
that much type [ __ ] so
at the end of my paycheck after like
bills and everything
included
i probably had maybe like 20 to my name
type [ __ ] yeah maybe by like you feel me
you know the nine to five you know
type of
type of jobs i feel you like just enough
to get by so even then we was doing
giveaways you know i'm saying that's
awesome
up were you living at back then
at that time i was staying on uh i was
right right there right there by the
head so you've been in your whole life
almost like your whole adult life you've
been chilling right there yeah wow man
so
it's like uh
i mean does the way does the way
nipsey's story ended make you weary
about doing this as you get bigger and
bigger
so
i mean i can't i can't really speak on
nipsey's death
but uh
i feel like if you're involved in the
lifestyle that we we grew up we all
share to me regardless of where we're
from
that's that's that's you know that's
we're always told that's the only thing
you promised i'm saying you're either
promised a coffin or a cell you know
what i'm saying so we kind of know what
we signed up for when
you know when we get involved and what
we get involved with
uh the only thing that i'm really
concerned about like
death is inevitable i'm saying
regardless of how i go
but uh the only thing i'm concerned
about is just fulfilling
my
what i'm my purpose as a human being on
this earth
until that day comes
so until then i'm gonna just keep doing
what i'm doing and just work you know
give back in any way i can you feel me
hoping i leave a good legacy behind to
those who really knew me and and and
what i did
and aside that she you know just raised
raised my kid and and
everything else is just you for me how's
your kid
she turned six in me oh now okay so
you're not a brand new dad you've been
doing this yeah since and i wasn't here
for her birth
i was when you were in jail yeah i
paroled when she was 11 months so i made
it just before i made it home just
before her first birthday
and since then i've been uh
i've been with her [ __ ] the majority
of the time like everybody thinks
because you're on the road
working
um you know like when do you ever see
your daughter he probably don't see his
daughter like bro like any time i'm not
working she with me like i'm always with
her all the time
that's good man i mean
i feel like you're just trying to set an
example for yourself it's set an example
like do good and people might want to do
good [ __ ] too thanks it's it's true like
you gave those shoes away maybe that
valedictorian kid [ __ ] gets a baller
ass job later and starts doing the same
[ __ ] ten years ago
you never [ __ ] know who you're
inspiring or who you're who's looking
and going
i'm gonna change the way i think because
of that because you just said all that
[ __ ] i just looked at mario like
i gotta do more [ __ ] cause i get you
know like helping homies paying bill
like all that [ __ ] comes with being a
person yeah but like going out and like
hey stranger because i told you my idea
i want to be a billion i mean obviously
everyone's been a billionaire but once i
get to a point where i'm not tripping i
just want to go around like yo here's
five stacks
lady at the at the at the mall like
because you remember back to school like
yo you know we can't get that [ __ ] i
don't want to stress my mom out thinking
she needs to give me a cloak no she
can't yeah but you know you ever walk by
and just got away someone just dropped
money on us one day it's going to happen
that's going to be here and my mom's
told me that uh senior year
high school she's like you have to wear
the same [ __ ] as last year because i
can't buy you clothes this year and one
of my boys
uh heard and he stepped up and was like
it's good i got you damn that's a good
[ __ ] homie right there i told him i
was like i was like what do you want to
return like
i'll go rob anybody i'll shoot anybody
for you
but he was like the only thing i want to
return is for you to graduate that was
my last year that was deep so that's
still [ __ ] with that homie
yeah he locked up right now he's been
locked up the last decade but
uh you know i'm awaiting his
you know his that's a good person man
that's some good [ __ ] right there i have
my shout out to spencer
if he didn't help me eat food in the
senior year i wouldn't eat [ __ ]
every day give me two dollar two thirty
too many chickens every [ __ ] that's
the only thing i ate man
[ __ ] shout out to spencer bro my mom
moved she like gave up all her rides my
dad was all [ __ ] up so i lose my
grandpa but i was like too embarrassed
to ask my grandpa for money
like living at his house already like
i'm already a burden
around trump yeah even though he didn't
feel that way
i just you know what i mean you don't
want to ask somebody for funny yeah i've
been like that with my brother
i didn't have a place to stay like a
couple times you feel me like
we really like this [ __ ] we didn't know
about each other like we really like
had to stay on my brother's couch type
[ __ ] so i could save up enough money to
move
and i feel it like you don't even want
to ask nope you're going closer
yeah that's my brother yep i don't even
want to leave the bathroom yeah i feel
like i feel like a [ __ ] bird yeah
i feel that yeah [ __ ] out of that so
yeah so yeah if you got homies and you
can help and it's always the person that
stays a little later [ __ ] that
might be wearing the same [ __ ] all the
time notice these little traits because
that was me bro that was [ __ ] me
like everybody's eating like y'all eat
that [ __ ] too because i'm [ __ ]
starving man
so no i i appreciate hearing [ __ ] like
that because like you said well he's
locked up right now but that doesn't
mean he's a bad [ __ ] right
everybody's doing just he just wants you
to do good be successful you pass it on
right now those [ __ ] valedictorians
got j's and they're like look what i've
got yeah yeah little things bro yeah
even a sticker like with fans yo bro
he's like a shirt
yes yeah it's the smallest [ __ ] and you
made that fool's day yeah it's the
smallest [ __ ] that that that makes the
biggest difference it's a weird feeling
huh knowing that you could be like hey
what's up and that makes a day like
sometimes even more yeah just like a
follow back or a dm anything type [ __ ]
i'm like bro that's crazy yeah it's
crazy i mean it's you don't think about
i know you don't yeah i know you don't
think about it but when you actually
think about like i'm so [ __ ] happy
that we can do this because if you make
someone you know growing up who'd you
look up to
silence same here he's gonna give a good
answer i know it's not easy what that's
not easy i didn't want to give a good
answer honestly like though i didn't i
didn't have a role model that i wanted
to be like because there wasn't nobody
but uh even like it's like my dad like
you know with all due respect i didn't
want to be like my dad i'm saying
because same you know what i'm saying
did you grow up with your dad around
he was he was the type he was like a
provider
oh okay walking don't say [ __ ] to you
just go back to work yeah i'm [ __ ]
paying the bill don't [ __ ] talk to me
i'm saying my whole life
so
i didn't look up to somebody like that
you feel like i said without due respect
i love my dad and [ __ ] but
um
i looked up to the rappers
the people that i was listening to my uh
and and and and and the headphones are
in the boom box
you feel me anything from like 96
up until you know i was like i
paroled the first time your whole life
man yeah just rap that's all i kind of
had to resort to so wait growing up in
merced who are you who you listen to
growing up are you influenced by an
older brother or cousin or something
cause that's usually how it sparks you
know right now so i'm the youngest of
eight
damn
holy [ __ ] you got 40 year old sisters
i think i have that's a trip bro so my
mom had my oldest brother when she was
15 right so she had him yeah that's my
my sister same age yeah she hannah was
just 15. i'm not too sure the exact age
they are i'm just saying like you got a
[ __ ] big family dude you have four
brothers four you got one two if you
want to drink it's up to you
i drink tequila go for it uh yeah let's
take a little drink break but uh
youngest of eight
yeah but everybody's from a different
era
i'm saying obviously the oldest one
isn't into the [ __ ] i am how how old's
the gay age gap
like i said i don't know his exact age
is he over 40 though like i would say
he's probably over 40 more young saying
yeah maybe 40 something
uh i do know like in the ninth sometime
in the 90s i know when i was like
five maybe he was probably 18 type [ __ ]
oh so there's a gauge gap yeah
so but there's like one year apart type
c
so the next one is like
younger a year younger a year younger
and then there was like a little gap
like a four-year gap and then parents
are fighting yeah yeah and all right
let's have more kids yeah
so
everybody
what was dope about that was that i got
into his music like damn he probably
listens to 80s [ __ ] yeah
so i got into that
so i'm a little bit of everywhere yeah
you fit me but the one that just [ __ ]
got me was hip hop and rap
yeah a lot of old school uh like 90s
hip-hop
you know the tupac's
the uh the death rows she pretty much
bet on point with this show right here
right that's what all we talk about okay
right so but i kept up with the hip-hop
uh
revolution
evolution i mean
um
you know to the early 2000s to when you
know all right no not what i'm saying
the little john so how does it feel
about to be on the fizzler growing up as
a kid and i know you're [ __ ] with a
thizzler and this music this
entertainment yeah that [ __ ] was so
popular when we were kids in merced bro
and now i just saw you on the this one
that's when i went no [ __ ] way it
[ __ ] uh
i i don't know i kind of manifested a
lot of this [ __ ] like without even
knowing i kind of spoke it into
existence
i was in prison and then uh
my boy jay uh his name's pj
i'll call him jpeg
uh pj from san jose he was my upstairs
neighbor
so we would talk through the vent
and uh
we would talk about that [ __ ] he's like
because i see i told him i was like i
want to rap when i get out
and he's like man you got to get that
dizzler interview when you get out what
i'm saying
and then we would both say that shout
out to this for help and [ __ ] make it
in the beginning a little tag
and uh that's all it was
and then he reminded me a few years
after
he's like bro you finally got that
disney i was like oh [ __ ] i forgot we
used to talk about that [ __ ] that's
badass yeah and then the way i heard
about you
was when i was working at that company
rotoblast
we was taking i was taking my break
and if i remember correctly his name was
israel hernandez i think
and he's like
he was a cool funny dude right
he i think i want to say he was i don't
know if he was from merced chiller type
[ __ ] but
he was like you heard the dope as yola i
was like nah i have it you know i've
been absent in a couple years i'm saying
oh you just got out yeah yeah yeah
uh
i didn't i didn't you know even if i if
i was out like i was only focused on the
street [ __ ]
i wasn't too worried about what else was
going on
so
he's like yeah he's from merced he does
uh this podcast
he does his story time podcast
so i checked you out
and i was like uh i watched like bits
and because you know you only got like
10 15 minutes yeah i watched a couple of
different clips and i was like damn this
dude's [ __ ] funny
and uh
i've always been the story telling guy
you know what i'm saying yeah and the
music especially bro yeah yeah the music
and
like when you have bunk like sally's
bunkies
i was always the one just i got stories
for days about any topic yeah so when i
started watching your [ __ ] the clips i
was like bro if anybody's gonna out
story tell me it's gonna be this guy you
know what i'm saying
that can't ain't nobody got more stories
than me type [ __ ] is how i feel
so i [ __ ] uh i dm'd you
i don't know if you remember but i was
like hey uh you know i just got caught
onto your [ __ ] you're just dope you know
you're dope whatever
and uh
you were like yeah it's crazy i just see
you from her sad type [ __ ] oh it's like
a year something to go at least
because the first time i heard you're
like merced yeah i say it was fight two
years ago
and uh
and i thought it was dope that you even
replied because your numbers were
already so hot i tried i tried bro
i was like dad this dude's like humble
enough to reply so i felt pretty dope
about that and that was it
months went on year that year and a half
then everybody just kind of started like
hey you know you need to do this you
need to do this i was like you know
it'll happen and when it happens you
know what i'm saying and then you tapped
in i was like oh [ __ ] like
it took a while but it you know i got
like history behind how you know
how long i've been waiting or
i'm excited
that's how most things go like this it
is it is it's like a miss miss it'll
happen perfect right when it needs to
yeah when you're trying to make it music
like all big for me all the best
situations happen like that like you
connect and then you kind of get to know
each other just a little bit you watch
each other or whatever and then when the
time's right you circle back yeah yeah
yeah it's just destiny that's the way it
works yeah dude the first time i heard
about you someone tagged me
on a merced video and that's why i told
you like is that mcnamara park
so who the [ __ ] is making music at
mcnamara part as i haven't heard this
[ __ ] since i was 18 people trying to
make music in merced
i'll come back to what i was going to
ask you but uh
what's up guys this ad read right now
from one of our sponsors you may want to
take advantage of if you've been
watching for the past couple weeks you
know we've been working with c seatgeek
seatgeek is the best app you could
possibly use to find the cheapest
tickets for any sporting event any
concert anything all you do download the
app go on the website say you want to go
watch a soccer game type it in what seat
do you want type that seat in click the
area if it pops up green that means it's
the best deal you're gonna get if it
pops up red it means it's not a good
deal but it doesn't mean it's not for
sale you could still buy it but i would
try to get the one with the green dots
and you already know from personal
experience i use c geek and have uc geek
for a very long time so i actually used
my own code when i was in new york which
was crazy using our own code to get
money off so right now if you go to
seekgeek and use our code dope as usual
that's going to get you 20 off of your
very first ticket that right there is
basically free parking and you got that
20 off just by using our code dope as
usual you guys know me i am not tech
savvy i'm not very good with all this
stuff see geek i can do go outside go do
stuff go have fun go be with your
friends but remember if you want to save
twenty dollars download the seek geek
app use our code dope as usual and
that's 20 bucks off your first ticket
taking a moment to talk about one of our
long time sponsors miller light first
off thank you for all the pictures all
the dms of you guys drinking miller
light and watching the show we really
appreciate that right now go
forward
to
millerlite.com
that's going to take you to a landing
page that landing page is going to take
you to the closest spots in your area
that deliver beer and or go to any place
that sells beer and get a meal light so
if you're hanging out with your homies
you guys are drinking why not grab some
real lights go to the store get them
hang around cook your hot dogs cook your
things it's summertime remember 96
calories 3.2 grams of carbs per can per
12 ounces so for all the guys out there
at the pool with your shirt off i know
you care about that but for those out
there that like light beer that actually
tastes like beer and not water grab
yourself from real life and remember
every time you drink it you're
supporting the show from milwaukee to la
from wherever you're watching thank you
guys so much for grabbing my life thank
you for supporting us remember that guys
millerlight.com forward slash yola use
that code at the end it's going to take
it all the places that deliver beer so
you don't got to drive celebrate
responsibly for the miller brewing
company milwaukee wisconsin so thank you
guys so much for watching back to the
episode
that's the first time i heard you i'm
like get the [ __ ] out of here from
merced do they have studios and [ __ ]
mercedes are you just guys doing this i
never yeah i never uh
i think one of my boys once had this in
his garage but like i know you're on m
street
it was i don't remember i was talking
about the make it slap people i don't
know
i know who you're talking about but i
don't think i've ever [ __ ] with any of
them
uh like
that was way before my time wait before
i was like 18 years old bro this is a
lot okay a little older than me because
i think that my three years older than
you yeah i think i was like yeah a
little younger than that
but i know who you're talking about yeah
yeah of course because merced so small
ain't nothing ever came out of there a
site like lowdown i don't know if you
remember lowdown
back in like the 90s
paperboy
boy did too people had a single though
yeah as a singer
yeah
he's from merced that's just hard he
blew up off that single ap nines from
her set too
went to hoover yeah he [ __ ] uh i
think his parents level a lot bro they
used to live on lapras oh okay
and then like i was saying uh
uh dela moved to merced for a while i
remember that [ __ ] yeah so there was
there was there's been a couple of
people that yeah there's a few in and
adam are saying they know of it merced
the pit stop between like yo they got
mad packs here because everybody stops
from the [ __ ] up north between la
that's the drop-off point we got a lot
of [ __ ] fire i'll say that about
myself
got some fire ass weed that's true yeah
because yeah we're right in the middle
of it we're in the middle and that's
another thing like
music wise i'm not gonna get off topic
but
we right in the middle of like l.a and
the bay
so anytime we do anything it's more like
especially with music i see like oh you
know why you guys trying to sound like
the bay why are you guys trying to be
like l.a for sure i'm like bro like
we're in the middle of it so
whatever's going to the bay from la or
whatever's going to lay from the bay
we're intercepting all that [ __ ] so we
[ __ ] with both of you yeah cause the
first time i heard you talk i'm like
he's from merced he sounds like he's
from
like oakland like the way he's talking
like he might be from like
right outside of oakland he sounds like
that's why it hasn't from her said but
like you're
it's
it's how you grow up like i told you
today i all my slang [ __ ] is new york
[ __ ] i just barely went there i don't
know why when i heard them like yo you
guys sound like me what the [ __ ] is that
crazy
so i i when i first time i heard you
that's when i was like this falls from
merced
and then i saw like a year later when
everybody tagged me on your video you
had a video come out a music video i got
like i'm telling you [ __ ] hundreds of
tags back to back in my dms
non-stop like yo from merced holy [ __ ]
and then i told you about remember i
told you i'm like there's a rapper
coming out of her set and he's brown and
that's something like he's [ __ ] brown
bro
it's awesome to see like yeah holy [ __ ]
because
our whole town looks like us
so when they see you they're like yo
he's from here you know he's from here
right yeah and it's like an inspiring
thing to see like
we could do it we could do this if you
could do it we can it's possible yeah
it's dope it's dope too uh
it's cool yeah it's i don't know i don't
got much to say about it because this is
crazy to me still yeah for sure i get i
get what you're saying because it's
yourself you don't want to think about
that way but outside perspective looking
in i get hyped i don't even live in
merced right now but i'm like no [ __ ]
way yeah because you want to see
something good exactly you know i want
to see something yeah good come out of
that [ __ ] unless
you're a hater of course yeah there's a
whole group of those but we're not
talking about them yeah now if i were to
see somebody from even when i was seeing
something about some of my boys uh
you know popping with the rap [ __ ] way
before i even started
i was like bro like that's motivational
i could probably do that someday you
know i was never like
that's a [ __ ] that should be me
yeah i was nervous
i would have probably never got nowhere
with them you won't in life bro yeah
those are the [ __ ] that i hate
this [ __ ] job why am i getting paid
so little this motherfucker's the idiot
he gets paid more than exactly yeah
that's because you that right there is
why yeah
that mentality can you change your
perspective about you say you've spoken
to musicians so you believe in
manifestation all that [ __ ] right that's
true every time we talk about it we talk
about someone that's doing something
successful it's like i kind of just
spoke it into existence whether you
realize everyone does it
yeah it's real
yeah it's it's
before you know it you're at a certain
point in life that you don't even know
how the [ __ ] you got there
you know what i'm saying
um and that's just how it's been for me
i just like that i don't even know
what's your like recording process been
as far as working with producers and
just actually
making the music and putting it out
well any i mean
anybody can make anybody can rap anybody
can make music you know
me like when i make a song i try my best
to try to tell you something in my song
you feel me
try to you know have a concept to it at
least not just rap about
one thing or the same thing
the way i learned this excuse me
is
when i was in a pen
i would rap to you know a lot of
different you know
people from different backgrounds and
ethnicities and stuff like that
different walks of life everybody
different
you know you got asians whites blacks
these daniels
all type of different people you know
what i mean
so when you start rapping you become
kind of like
a form of entertainment in there so you
get like a cool decent crowd
but you don't got a beat
and then you don't got the mixing and
mastery and applied to the to the track
you don't got the effects you don't got
all that
so right now it's just your word and
what you can do with your hands and uh
even then like i was like bro like i
need to really say something in order to
keep all these people
lifers [ __ ]
straight [ __ ] you know some of the
hardest gangsters in
in cali
entertain type [ __ ] and they got to be
some real [ __ ] or else they go they
ain't gonna feel it type [ __ ]
so
that's when my my writing process kind
of changed i was like but i actually
gotta talk about some real [ __ ] have
some substance yeah so that's when
that's that's that's that's kind of how
i i the storytelling became came about
you for me
uh because
you know with a beat and
with all the edits that come along with
it anybody can make a dope song but when
you
could really just spit some yeah because
it's like how much music do i want to
put out versus how much do i really want
to sit here and think about what i'm
saying and really mean this [ __ ] like i
have a theme to it right so that's how i
started making music just kind of
rapping about what we lived through what
we've seen in merced
and [ __ ] felt it
so right now i still try to keep the
same concept talking about life you know
daily struggles everybody kind of deal
with
and uh in the hood
but now that i got a a a solid fan base
it it allows me to uh
you know kind of venture off into
different
you feel me uh
vibes and stuff like that now i can make
party music and i can make
sure like so because you have enough fan
base that like at least a portion of
them are gonna [ __ ] love it yeah and
those who know like
i could spit they're gonna be like oh
well we know he could spit so he could
kind of you know he he can get away with
this you know he can get away with this
one because we know he got bars type
[ __ ] yeah so that's just kind of where
i'm at right now like i just play a beat
first
i got a lot of go-to producers
um but i originally started with merc on
the beat i'm not going to be from reset
too i don't know if you know i don't but
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah man started
with merc making beats i started one
admirer he from merced too
uh it was just a trio from her set beats
rapper
director
all three of us not knowing what the
[ __ ] we was doing
failed hella times and it just after a
while i just worked
and it's just
that's just how what kind of routine are
you in as far as like writing and
recording is it like constantly well
right now i'm a lot busier than what i
once was before i would just
sit in the whip at night
or put on some headphones and try to you
know
write to certain beats that i have
now i got beats for [ __ ] days that i
could just
do
oh gotcha now because the beats are
expensive beats are a couple hundred
dollars even sometimes it could be a
couple thousand type [ __ ]
so depending on the producer you're
working with
but
back then i was like bro i'm putting my
life savings into this one b you know
what i'm saying yeah and i gotta do what
i can with it now it's just like i got a
shitload of beats i can pick from uh so
now the hardest thing for me is just
finding the time to write because i'd be
so busy
like i was telling you earlier i just
opened up a new
sneaker shop what's it called where's it
at so it's been a it's right next to
byroid oh so it's on that side of town
it's on 12th and martin luther king oh
[ __ ] like i was just saying like
maybe i'll walk to that part
but i was a kid like don't go over there
you got to keep it in the hood type [ __ ]
i love it man what's it called it's
called certified kicks nice with a z at
the end certified kicks and then
it's [ __ ] uh you mean it's just it's
a little small
business but it it is dope to to yours
man yeah to kind of just be able to you
know [ __ ] with the city on a different
level like i'm usually
used to doing community service for the
city type [ __ ]
now i get to kind of be in the office
with y'all type [ __ ] on this in prison
or did this just happen it just happened
i mean i've always followed nipsey's
blueprint you know what i mean
uh he's one of the ones that why i
recently why
you know kind of just i'm successful in
a way you know
uh he just
he's he's he's he's he's a real
[ __ ] he grew up in a gang
banging environment
and uh you know he he he faced the odds
and
beat the odds and
uh for a [ __ ] like me i'm like
there's nobody in merced that's ever
done that so i got a resort to somebody
out of town
and it just so happened to be like nip
and then when mazzy started blowing up
too i started [ __ ] with the mods
because i would run into them every now
and then
and um i was like bro it's tough to see
[ __ ] blow up like that and make
something happen
because it makes you think like okay i'm
in this small pond but that's actually
my advantage because i could just be
this could be i could blow this [ __ ] up
right that's like what griselda did i'm
from buffalo it's what griselda just did
i don't know
but yeah it makes it like oh yeah it's
like it's my [ __ ] like how you're saying
with his [ __ ] like i'm gonna start where
i'm at what's in front of me yeah yeah
what i got you feel me we obviously
don't got
we're not where we want to be but we're
definitely on the way
very far from where we came from you
know what i mean from where we started
so right now it's just keeping on like i
said
i still don't always know what i'm doing
like we're going to try it though until
it works
if it don't work we're going to try a
different route and
you know we we're going to be all right
i think persistence man
yeah what about like performing live are
you on the road and doing shows and
stuff yeah yeah so i when i first
started popping
i had a lot of shows lined up
different places in cali
but uh right now i just uh hired a
booking agent smart just because i'm too
busy to it's another job yeah i'm not
wrong i can't i can't do that [ __ ] so
he from her set too by johnny [ __ ] okay
hold on real quick i don't mean to
interrupt you i looked in your bio and
it says
contact johnny boyd lopez yes
is this the same johnny boy lopez used
to make music he was rapping bro
i remember where i was sitting at the
push trees house before i ever started
me i remember uh chill with rosie i was
on the computer my i had and i put on
[ __ ] youtube because my homie vince
said you should check out this new
johnny boy and i put it on as a video of
him in a shopping cart in the save mart
parking lot oh yeah i've seen this i
remember when he dropped that that's
when it came out and it came out i
watched him like
from merced huh
i love it like i thought it was the
coolest [ __ ] ever yeah and then i saw
him in your bio bro it's like get the
[ __ ] out of here so yes so he loved it
it was good [ __ ] he would do hella shows
and [ __ ] like that he'll stay on the
road all year long right
regardless of of where he's at with his
music career he has that experience
and he has you know contacts and
different venues all over the country
so i was like bro like
i don't got time for this [ __ ] i know
this dude and i know what he can do yeah
so let me just hire him
and you know we've been you know
communicating i think he might have
texted me during this interview so i'm
gonna text him when i get back but
yeah it's just like bro let's keep it in
in the town and he's been doing a
[ __ ] excellent job at it so i do i do
got upcoming ones
but uh
i don't i think i've maybe done one or
two shows since the pandemic uplifted
but uh yeah i'm definitely excited to
get back on that's where you get your
money i feel like as an artist
street promo i'm regular i'm used to
like the old school street promo you got
you get out there in the streets and
and do it rather than social media
social media is definitely a great
platform to
to uh you know promote a market
but i think the street promo something
else like
a [ __ ] could could order your
merch from online but let's say dope is
yola goes to
merced sets up a booth with all that
[ __ ]
it's different
no i got it it's gonna be like what the
[ __ ] he actually came
you know what i'm saying yeah the way
you're doing is the way i saw artists
when i was growing up more like the bay
area artists like you talking about
dillon all these fools the pop-ups the
shows and everything was was
the it was everything meet the artist
buy some [ __ ] from the artist yeah smoke
up a lot with the hardest it's a whole
different i met a clip though when i was
a kid
i still remember i was [ __ ] 14 years
old i met a crypto he smoked a joint
with us
right i [ __ ] with his i love that you
know who i'm talking about right now
i'm everywhere with the music [ __ ] i may
not always talk about it or mention
every artist i [ __ ] with yeah but i
definitely went through that this
phase dj fresh all this [ __ ] back dre
had me wanting to be black i wanted to
be black during the this area when
you're a kid yeah i was like bro like i
want to be just like mac drake
and uh
yeah but i know you crypto
andre nicotina doobie the mob figures
doobie i remember they remember
yeah i remember when burner started uh
you know rap my first mixtape from him
was uh
the uh
weekend at bernie's i think is what it's
called and then uh yeah with the two
females have that yeah yeah and uh the
one with an pacino oh you're talking
about uh
oh uh jacka and pacino or bernard pacino
albums i have all of them yeah there's
bernard pacino and there's bernie jacket
that's got traffic
oh yeah it had brakes on the back i have
this album oh i have an extent it had
breaks of coke on the back right i was
just stupid on burner when he came out
uh all type of people from the bay you
know what i mean it's just like
you're the same you're you're you're
watching and listening the same [ __ ] i
was listening
oh i got a hell of a lot my [ __ ]
mixtapes bro
wow limewire jay stalin i got the
[ __ ] limewire shirts stalin my
license plates reeds [ __ ] dairy style
i hate it like all that [ __ ] when
self-made millionaire came out crazy no
middleman with him and burner
i really thought he was going to blow
the [ __ ] up off that song i thought that
was like the radio one like it was a
good song you know which one got him uh
i i think got him around a lot too uh
i'm getting cake like my birthday yeah
you know who jay stalin is probably not
huh not so much i met him one time see
these little interactions man you
remember forever i was in
the catalyst in santa cruz
they left me upstairs i was like [ __ ]
17 they let me upstairs in the 21
section because i know they're so fresh
people and i met jay stalin and i better
never forget that [ __ ] like i was a
little kid he was mad cool so thanks for
listening man he walked off so i was
like 20 years ago
i still remember this [ __ ] so like these
little interactions like you giving back
you giving the play to the dude sparked
this and just the genuine genuine
organic
community is what i'm seeing
yeah you know like i really [ __ ] with it
and now you have a store so
what's the address for everybody out
there that wants some shoes don't go to
the mall don't go to shake
like we don't need another shoe in there
damn i haven't been in the mall in a
minute man
okay if if you know
i don't know when when the last time you
went to the mall was but i [ __ ] you
recently recently half of it's closed
yeah it's all closed it's probably like
four floors open half of a [ __ ] was
closed and there's like a fruit guy like
yeah that [ __ ] works here yeah
yeah no cap i didn't even know he was i
don't even walk that far into the mall i
just went to the uh i had to get shoes i
forgot i stopped at the foot actually
and that's it yeah the footage at my
homie shout out to alan let's just see
you out there this is your mom i just
stopped by the foot action uh i think
yesterday but uh
yeah they all got [ __ ] in there anyway
what i'm saying is there's a bunch of
jar malls dying you know when your
town's just oh no economically
moss says a lot about your [ __ ] times
mcdonald's will never go anywhere that's
pretty much it on our street everything
else is up for [ __ ] debate man uh-huh
yeah
you got a dollar store and a foot locker
that's what every mall crumbles down to
at some point
i [ __ ]
um another music question like coming up
completely independent right like you're
doing all this [ __ ] yourself has
streaming been substantial for you like
are they are those platforms really do
you feel like supporting you in terms of
like paying you back for growing your
fan base through as far as royalties
that's what i first depended on
to quit my job oh [ __ ] because i didn't
have a form of income aside but you did
it though
yeah so
after a while like i knew what i wanted
to do right
i knew i wanted to make music
but
i wasn't you feel me i still had
responsibilities i had a daughter
her mom that i had to take care of
excuse me it's like an expensive thing
you're trying to fund through yes and
it's not the same [ __ ] story it's not
nothing cheap like bro like
you really need to invest a lot of
[ __ ] money into one song yeah
god help me if you're getting a [ __ ]
future working with the big producers
yeah yeah yeah facts so
i was like before i quit i got to make
sure i'm making enough
so i think i was getting paid average
500 a week right off streams no no no oh
just
work okay i was like damn
a week for uh
for work from my nine to five that's a
good [ __ ] paying job in reset man
right and then so i was like i multiply
by four i'm getting two bands a month
right
and
i was like
the moment i get two bands a month off
royalties i'ma quit my job because you
know why why work if i make enough
uh if i make the same should i make it
now
so
it started off for like a dollar fifty a
month that i would get off royalties
then it bumped up to like three dollars
then they went to like five bucks
and this was every month so it was
working working were you deliberate from
the start or when you started putting
out music like i'm going to publish this
[ __ ] i was consistent up to what i knew
because i didn't have nobody teach me i
didn't have a manager and i have you got
to figure all that you just did the
shakes you wanted to do this yeah yeah
everything yeah i would on my spare time
i would
be on google and youtube trying to
research you know what works what
doesn't
um and like i said it was just trial and
error music publishing is confusing as
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah honestly i didn't know there was
percentages and royalties and
all this other [ __ ] i didn't know about
so
i kind of just forgot about it
and then i was like the [ __ ] is this
that's that's casual
company that's theirs right there sent
out the canning company this thing looks
fancy
class tip
yeah and so
after that
[ __ ] if you're the president you're
doing the
percentages i'm still gonna let off
those couple hits
um
yeah after a while i just forgot about
it and then i was i got into like a lot
of different podcasts uh
i got into gary vee super tough at one
point and uh
you know you listen to those
motivational speakers
so
when i opened up my youtube in the
morning to go to work and play some
music
it was like you know do you hate your
life do you do are you at a point where
you know you're not supposed to be doing
this
i would get a bunch of those ads pop up
and then the supervisor would kind of
piss me off because
you know he telling you what to do and
then you're just not having it
and then you get to the point where like
you know what [ __ ] this like when am i
going to get enough royalties to [ __ ]
quit my job
and this was months after i started so i
checked and and my royalties got like
they went up
so i was like oh [ __ ] i could quit my
job now oh [ __ ] so you checked in a
minute yes i hadn't checked in a minute
oh what a feeling so i'm just like oh
[ __ ] i was like
juiced
because this whole time i've been
dealing with people are like
you're not going to make it like don't
quit your day job's told you that bro i
[ __ ] not only that
but even like
it it no longer gets to me at all no
more oh no no but at the beginning what
though so you got out and people weren't
trying to support whatever yeah they
were just more like brother like
you know for real
type of [ __ ] nobody's ever been
successful merced with it what makes you
think you're gonna you don't mean type
[ __ ] that's why it's just like you're
against all odds right
so now i'm like juiced at that too i'm
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] actually worked
after everybody said it wouldn't
so i was like i'm gonna try to do two
more weeks
five now that's two more days
the [ __ ] supervisor was like bro we
need you to stay four extra hours over
time
and i'm like what the [ __ ] like
brian just did eight type [ __ ] you know
like
he's like nah bro i need you to stay
right
and i was like
he's like the company needs you i don't
give a [ __ ] with the government
i put in my time i'm ready to go home
type [ __ ]
so i was just like [ __ ] that i quit bro
like
i just left i walked off
and it felt like [ __ ] it was just such a
big weight off my shoulders
but then once i was like finally out
like walked off the of the
the
business you know perimeter
i was like damn like i [ __ ] quit like
what the [ __ ] what am i gonna do now i
was like what am i gonna do right i'm
like without feeling at first yeah it's
just so yeah
and then i went to my mom's my mom's
spot she's like come in with me she's
she's like she's like she's like you
didn't go to work today i was like i did
i quit and then she's like
[ __ ] dude like what are you like she's
like she was just you know give me you
know the mexican mom not like oh [ __ ]
like this kid you slap you in the arm
yeah
i don't know if she believed me or not
she probably thought i was [ __ ]
around but then after that she's like
you really quit
i was like yeah she's like what are you
gonna do i was like i'm gonna rap
and she's like this [ __ ] kid right
what the [ __ ] she's like dude you know
because
as a first generation mexican in this
country
you're just used to work pay bills and
that's it yeah we're like
enslaved in this you know
a lower class
femi
[ __ ] and i'm like nah bro like i've been
listening to garyvee i've been listening
to all these entrepreneurs that
they're telling me that there's a
different way out
and then they're just like
they're just so like such non-believers
i'm saying
they're like dude like you're listening
to a guy on the internet
it's scary to believe in yourself yeah
i'm just like bro like this [ __ ] gonna
work type [ __ ] and
i just never looked back i was like [ __ ]
i gotta make it work now
and it's been working
that's amazing
that's that's the real impact of
podcasting on people's lives i got to
[ __ ] happen yeah listen to happiness
shaped what you were going to do with
your life kind of or at least not shaped
expedited the process because you were
going to do it no matter what that's
what you refer to what he was doing he
kind of yeah he kind of like there you
go he gave me that hope that nobody else
did type [ __ ] everybody's like you're
not gonna make you're not nothing's
gonna happen
he's like do it if you fail [ __ ] it
exactly something else yeah exactly
you're always gonna have a job you can
always go back to that job
yeah you're right and you were smart for
not putting all your eggs in the music
you're like i'm gonna start my own
business and i'm gonna get this going
and i'm just gonna get a bunch of stuff
going yeah there's there's a lot of
different there's like a million ways to
make money out there yes or if not more
it's just you know and even at this
point
my boy was talking about it my boy right
here he got
if i'm not gonna tell you how much money
he got he got dough right
and just hearing them say something like
you know and my papa's almost saw
something like little chips and candies
too you feel me that's like a real
entrepreneur a real [ __ ]
hustler like i'm gonna [ __ ] how much
money i got like
i'm gonna keep
making doing [ __ ] to make [ __ ] work
makes it happen you know what i'm saying
like it isn't necessarily you know who
you are you don't have to own a
multi-million dollar company like nike
defend me but for a [ __ ] like us
something
never stops yeah some some anything is
like some to us you feel me exactly
we're gonna make some [ __ ] happen
whether it's a clothing brand
whether it's
cannabis
we're gonna kick so we're gonna make
something happen you feel me whatever
feels right you know and and you know
that's the start of something different
in in our family tree you know now i can
pass this on to my daughter
i'm not gonna
now i'm like if you want to go to
college that's on you so but you got to
do something you got to pursue a career
you know you got a talent you want to
pursue by all means go
go for it maybe
chase your dreams
i'm not going to be the same [ __ ] like
my parents not saying that they were bad
parents but
i'm not they're old school man they're
old school yeah they're going to be like
that's not going to work i'm not going
to tell my daughter that i'm going to be
there
i'ma help you find whatever you want to
do
and i'm going to help you make it happen
and if you fail that's fine it's not
wrong with failing yeah and hopefully
you know it gets passed on you're going
to find out what you're passionate about
that's what i want for my kids exactly
yeah so this is
you know it's it's endless it's endless
with
with what we do you know what i mean you
know like sky's the limit for real of
course of course so
do you have anything coming out any big
projects coming out soon already out
like full
albums coming out or anything like
what's your
right now you're just trying to do
anything you can do right now right i'm
just putting music like you said earlier
i don't know what i'm doing but i'm
going to get it done yeah that's what i
say every day but i don't know yet yeah
but we'll get it it's literally verbatim
when i say i don't know yet but we'll
[ __ ] do it tight
that's that's the
motivation to have inside like i'm me
[ __ ] i'm gonna do something cool
i'm gonna do something where i'm like
i'm proud yeah that's what you're doing
right like i don't know shoe story we're
[ __ ] merced right next to the place
where you started this whole thing out
yeah yeah come on man this is full
circle [ __ ] this is cool i didn't know
any of these things that's why i like
yeah this is great to hear coming out of
the place right down the street where i
i love the show this is i love it man
yeah it's crazy
um
as far as an album yeah i'm i'm wrapping
up an ep right now
i got two eps i'm working on what does
that mean you know what that means
extended play it means is that lp's
limited play it's like a short run ep's
like a full-length album and that means
like an actual owl
no well this one's going to be an actual
like short album
what i mean by i mean there might be
different meanings for different genres
but the one that i'm used to is like an
early project
so it's like a pre-album for your album
type [ __ ] it's like a mixtape kind of
like a mixtape oh okay okay yeah there's
a different term for it yeah yeah so
so how many songs
roughly i'm aiming for like seven you
know what i mean sometimes oh okay
something to hold you down for a little
bit while i keep working on the album
you know what i mean
so i got two of them i'm working on
um i got a music video
tonight
right after this driving right san
francisco isn't that crazy i got one
tomorrow in merced with my boy admirer
and then i got one uh this weekend in
hawaii so that's three music videos in
like three days span you know working i
feel like videos are probably the best
way you can spend your time as like an
uh music artist like yeah short little
music a lot of clips out yeah effects
uh i'm working on that
um i wanted to just completely blitz it
with the music i got a little carried
away with uh
with the with the sneaker shop you know
i wanted to be in there the first couple
weeks to see how it ran and
see how you know things work
because like i said i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is you know i really gotta
do
so i wanted to you know just
be there you'll figure it out yeah
before i hired an employee and now that
i got 100
yeah so then you know i'm at that point
now
that took up the majority of
of of you're moving fast
like you're [ __ ] crushing it bro yeah
that's what i did i packed orders until
[ __ ] three five months ago and then i
had to sit with them like you do right
all right i can be i can do my other
things yeah no that's facts and i i i
don't know what i represent you when i
started my merch
i was what's it called it was uh well
the label it just started different like
the label it was like the music label
was street certified block approved you
know
but it was just ghetto boy merch like gb
martial okay got you now i started a new
corporation recently a couple weeks ago
it's called a big league congratulations
corpses and all that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
so
so and that's a shout out my boy my boy
helped me do that you know he helped him
all the legal stuff out the way
but it's called big league so i'm
working on that now
but before it was uh just gb merch just
just the artist's name yeah
and i would come to la
buy this stuff in bulk
buy like the vinyl and all the stuff
that i'm doing it was like heat press
and i would just press them package them
and sling them out the trunk
press your own shirts man yeah all of
them yeah
and deliver it and all this [ __ ]
so i'm like that's how i started with so
we you know
we just we just you know focused on the
progress i'm so sorry if you're coming
up
so you're gonna i love that i can
already see how you're gonna do this
like that's what i loved about how
nipsey had the marathon like he didn't
call it the [ __ ] nipsy hustle store
the marathon was something everybody
could tap into everybody that's on a
marathon related to that [ __ ] but it was
his brand that just still tied into
everything like yeah i feel like that's
a super smart move to make to give back
to your fans yeah he was so smart like
we always talk about that like scan the
tag because i just dropped a new song
and now you got access to the [ __ ]
song from your tag all the stuff that's
going on the nfts and all that stuff
it's crazy
but that's that's why i decided to name
it bigly because
regardless of the work field you're in
or whatever
uh you're you know you're dedicated to
everybody wants to make it to the big
leagues you know
whether you you know you're on a podcast
you run a podcast you want to get to
those views
uh you you know cross that chasm yeah
you you play a sport i see the blueprint
you're doing that you know what i'm
saying so everybody want to make it to
the big leagues and
and that's kind of what inspired
the the the name of the new brand
and uh hopefully you know we got the
first
winner you know collection coming out
this year because
you know we just got all the legal work
done a couple weeks ago so now
what a feeling though right yeah did you
get that great book yet yeah that breaks
that ball isn't it crazy when you're
like i'm an adult now what though
yeah it's crazy it's weird huh yeah and
like i said like
like like like
a [ __ ] like myself that's you
know
into what i'm into and like you know got
the
the look going on and i'm mexican you
know what i mean
being like uh
in like banks and with the city with
with my [ __ ] going on like knowing what
i'm doing it feels good because
everybody look at you like
you know you don't belong but i'm just
like bro like i know what i'm doing
you know i'm in the same place here you
know what i'm saying like going back to
the school like you're saying like mr
schaefer like i don't like what you're
doing
yeah nice stuff
it's a it's i just love hearing this man
because i i don't get to like
i don't talk about this feeling a lot
because sometimes you think about like
damn these [ __ ] are staring at
me just give me five minutes you
understand why i'm here don't [ __ ] you
that's cool cause i know you get that
feeling too like because i look high all
day every
[Music]
you're on a different scale but they
look at me like
is your dad outside
that's how they look at me like a goofy
[ __ ] hot stinkin
and i'm like no this is my [ __ ] so i i
can relate to what you're saying i just
i just love seeing it man because
it's the first time i've ever got to
release now look it's becoming normal
out of merced for people to make it off
the internet yeah and who else who else
uh jalen green yeah that fools from
merced you see that yeah but he claimed
fresno
what yeah what do you mean like he said
it on the news
i have i don't know i think his his i
think his username has a five five nine
on it oh
yeah damn
yeah but yeah yeah easy oh man that kind
of hurts a little bit man i saw merced
california on the nba draft and lost my
[ __ ] mind i don't give a [ __ ] where
you're playing i support you this uh
five five nines is home
see that on this bio five five nine home
for no
he's very specific yeah oh i thought he
was from merced i think he got a five
five nine senate on his latest oh yeah
he must be from clovis or some [ __ ] oh
he must not be from reset then why they
put merced on this [ __ ] well they said
he they s that when they announced it
they said merced california they said i
got goosebumps yeah me too i was like
proud
unless he really is from her set and
just moved out there half
halfway through either way i was just so
happy to see it yeah i don't know but i
think things like that i still [ __ ] with
myself of course of course regardless of
where he claims or where he really is
from i don't i don't
i just thought it was great but but yeah
i feel like i was in the same like yeah
you know
reposted it tagged
you on twitter yeah i did like this
[ __ ] yeah i was all hyped up
dude that's what i'm saying about the
show
that's what i'm saying that uh you know
i never heard that you know dude before
that keep it a honey
either but just
seeing somebody make it out of merced i
was dope from i was rooting for him i
would reposted him tagged them that's
what's up you know what i mean it's
amazing so i couldn't see myself hating
like
oh yeah [ __ ] him who the [ __ ] is this
guy you know what i'm saying i don't
think you have it same [ __ ] with you
when i first heard you i was like bro
like your shit's dope you're funny
thanks bro well i didn't even hear the
song yeah i just saw mercy i went what
the [ __ ]
and instantly got hype and then watch
the video like that instantly like how
am i not going to be like you have that
home type of time like pride of like
we're behind you [ __ ] whatever
you do just do it good like making me
[ __ ] happy exactly you know like i
wish more people thought like that i
mean a lot dude i'm not trying to say
like everybody's a hater but i wish more
people were proud it would it would be
dope if we had some type of support you
feel me behind us like even then like it
would be dope to have like the city
support behind these give backs and
and uh oh yeah yeah for sure i think it
could be twice as big our city planner
is like 33 years old bro and i think our
mayor
the guy was running was like 29 years
old last time
we were we might be like on that path of
you know naming the street after your
ass in 10 years you never know like
that's the kind of pride [ __ ] that
i like i like this
how would you describe your fans like
where
do you like where did they come from
like how would you describe your your
average fan [ __ ] my fans are
i would just the ones i've met the ones
i've actually had encounters with and
heard stories of they're from all
different walks of life
not necessarily you feel me like the
gang banging background
but uh
kids who aren't in the gang banging
whites
asians blacks
um
all races uh all areas
everywhere i go everywhere i travel
texas washington
uh anywhere i go somebody knows me like
bro like you go crazy i [ __ ] with your
[ __ ]
i'd be at the gym or something
people walk up to me random strangers
like this is the song i'm playing right
now
and it's like halfway through one of my
songs
uh
a lot of law enforcement believe it or
not [ __ ] with my [ __ ] because they're
like bro like
they just back up what i'm doing like
this [ __ ] i remember arresting
this dude
[Music]
i know this i know the story he's
talking about in this song he's talking
about some real [ __ ]
and yeah you know we gonna do our job
and he gonna do what he do but aside
that i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with him i support
his music
a lot of them
might see me at the gas station or
something they'd be like hey bro keep
that [ __ ] up bro like that you should go
crazy type [ __ ]
and that should feel good so there
that's like my fan base is like
everybody
you know
all type of [ __ ] it's just it's
it's crazy that's good to hear it's
crazy oh i love this [ __ ]
i'd love to see it dude
it's very [ __ ] hell yeah the one
thing that i mean coming up kind of like
the generation
behind thomas like the one thing i want
everybody that should learn from thomas
is like feed into the fan base talk to
the fans that's the whole that's your
strength that's how you keep your fans
represent you mm-hmm you know what i
mean ever heard of like a one will say
artistry oh that my fool must listen to
something something like dad don't
associate shitty people with the artist
but they do represent you
like our fan base 99.9 nice as [ __ ]
positive everyone's like yo i just got
that [ __ ] job i was talking about
last week in the comments like i see
[ __ ] i know people's names just
like you do i know you see the same
people popping up at the same pot oh
thanks for coming back
i know you do because you give a [ __ ]
you give a [ __ ] before the [ __ ] you
even had this going on yeah yeah so it's
just gonna explode even more it's crazy
what i try to do too like sometimes a
lot of the time that i notice
like for example you're wearing like one
of your shirts
i'll i'll be the type of [ __ ]
like a like if i i know when i see like
a a real sincere genuine die-hard gb fan
and you can just see it in their face
you know i just i'm the type like
take my shirt off and give it to you i'm
too fat for that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying type [ __ ]
look cool after this
though
oh yeah i keep shooting the trunk i keep
a little stack of stuff in the trunk
[ __ ] everywhere i know like
there you go and their faces like like
what the what the [ __ ] i'm at work yeah
that [ __ ] makes me so [ __ ] nice when
they take pictures that work for you in
their work clothes you're like oh yeah
oh yeah it's the best [ __ ] yeah you know
what i'm saying or about y'all i wish i
could take a picture but i'm
i just love knowing like because i was
working there like you said you're
working at the spotlight i was working
there and if i saw somebody i was like i
have [ __ ] with your [ __ ] man like my
birthday's a little better like oh that
phone is cool
[ __ ] yeah it just like you said earlier
isn't it amazing like just being
yourself can make people like happy yeah
yeah yeah and that's the best thing i
think we can take from any episode ever
yeah yeah and and a lot of people like i
ain't expect you guys are chilled as
[ __ ] and funny as [ __ ] dope as
[ __ ] on it on the podcast right
but you're looking it through a screen
yeah so now i'm like being face to face
i'm like oh [ __ ] like these same [ __ ]
yeah it's like it's like yeah it's real
[ __ ] it's not just something behind the
camera like you [ __ ] is that
the same [ __ ] oh no bro yeah like
brother like these [ __ ] is
doper in person yeah that's why i was
told right before you got here might he
say seven minutes out when you text me
like i can't wait to talk to this
because i know because just from talking
to you that gives a [ __ ] yeah someone
that gives a [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
early he's hella polite he's chill as
hell like i'm [ __ ] happy because i'm
not saying anybody's rude but i like
that's the way i am towards people
professionalism
[ __ ] he's on his [ __ ] yeah yeah and then
going back to frisk going
crushing it dude like you're crushing it
man like this is what i'd like to see
this is what i like people to see that's
why i wanted to have you on because it's
it's an inspirational thing because you
know there's the little version of you
right now five years behind you yeah
that's just seeing this and that's
you're there garyvee and and that's what
i'm hoping for that's that's the main
goal is just
let's keep it going let's let's let's
you know
i can't wait to see it or meet him like
damn yep and i'd be like man i seen you
on the dope as yola doubles usual
podcast
um
and i'm like oh [ __ ] like you were that
kid watching the one we talked about
yeah i've met those people i've talked
like
you have to like you talking about a
certain person or something like i met
you and like someone i connect with so
much
and it makes that [ __ ] way more
meaningful like not even like oh yeah i
got paid off it like no like you know
how many people came up like you that
you helped me so [ __ ] much
just by being yourself or doing what you
love and before you start thinking about
like before you even started you're at
work just
yeah one day man and you do the same
thing as me in the same town probably
the same time yeah that's a trip man
yeah it's crazy it's very cool i like to
see it i love this little self-serving
kind of vortex that just kind of like
gives it feeds itself between you and
the fans that's like that's what we can
do now yeah and let me know next time
you want to do one of these giveaways
because i'm down as [ __ ] this makes me
feel like
cause i just you know stash i probably
give away 30 pounds of weed over the
course of like six years just i drop
like little zips on my snapchat
yeah i do it everywhere like
someone's not gonna have to buy weed for
[ __ ] two weeks that's another 500
they're gonna like pocket i just i know
like how much it helps right and if i
can just do it that's a funny giving
away but i want to do some [ __ ] like
you're doing get back to this check it
out so like yeah i'm announcing it early
i don't know when this is gonna drop but
monday
okay monday
oh yeah so
next week i'm doing the uh i'm trying
i'm still debating on what artists to
bring california artists
uh to bring to the shop for a
meet and greet you know what i'm saying
i'll do a meet and greet you know bring
a a rapper that got some buzz in the
alley
come to the town to a shop that you can
actually come meet them take a picture
with them autographed if they got merch
they could bring their merch but that'd
be dope to have you there as well a lot
of people next week next to no next
month what's the what is it
we're kind of aiming for like the 27th
ish the weekend um
we can't maybe a week before or that
weekend
you have my number now let me know yeah
well i mean exactly rosie's having
surgery on the 21st so i might
so if it's a week before i'm i'm all i'm
perfect but she'll come with me but
she's gonna have like a major surgery
and [ __ ] so i kind of gotta be here my
little brother's gonna be here for a
month so i don't need to go off top i'm
just trying to think and plan dates
because this sounds like something i
would like to help out with man
like i said that's great i do them
everywhere but like i never really done
like
a merced it'd be crazy
like that would be [ __ ] awesome like
my number one goal before i ever started
like one day i have a billboard on 16th
right there on 59 and now there's a del
taco one there you know what i was
talking about when i was like i'm like
[ __ ] billboard one day something did
you have yeah no but i'm about to get it
i had one last month on 16th and v
oh wait wait right over the track yeah
oh
i saw one the other day for a weed shop
like three weeks ago like burners
mercedes yeah i saw him like yeah the
[ __ ] outta
here
they stay on it i think they might have
paid like the full year because it's a
trip bro shout out joe and josh i
introduce them to you too when you go
out there bro
cool as [ __ ] bro shout out burners
merced for real yeah there's like six
five four shops in merced dispensaries
what the
blows my mother's one on v street i
heard in the very end and there's one by
where bianchi and sun used to be i used
to haul tomatoes with my grand they're
all truck drivers off of belchers mom's
used to work there get the [ __ ] out of
here why was the little kid walking
getting country times all the time with
the change that was me with my dad the
truck driver that was me i used to be up
yankee all day dude yeah yeah i was i
was like six so i was
94.95 yeah i was like 96. yeah no wait
that was like
yeah that was me i was a little i was
running around my sister and [ __ ] i was
always at bianchi what the [ __ ]
yeah
that's that's blue fire got blue fire
man yeah and manzanita i heard i've
never been to these shops before i just
met the owner imagining the two he came
to the shop the other day he could do
too i just like the little
circle like yo yo i'm supporting you
[ __ ] cuz this is tight
and on top it's from my town
this is the biggest thing for me man
and that's why i'm so excited for you to
be here and then to hear your story now
i'm like
i want to do more [ __ ] yeah i'm just
always thinking about doing like so much
[ __ ] i gotta do
i would love to do some [ __ ] man we'd be
too busy to you know respond to certain
dms
uh respond to certain comments you just
got a booking agent like respond to
certain calls certain messages i've been
like bro you think i'm like damn bro my
phone i didn't even see this i'm not
even ignoring you i might have opened it
and just kind of you know i'll get back
to it later and forgot
but yeah we'd be so busy we forget to do
a lot of things i'm saying
uh but yeah definitely you know you got
to start delegating all that at a
certain level yeah you're at that point
you're on you're super hands on and none
of this i just yeah i just like to be
hands-on i just let go though i'm a
perfectionist you stayed at the store
right i didn't let me touch my packages
for eight years
because i'm like nah no one's gonna pack
the [ __ ] better than i will because when
i when you open that i want you to go
this didn't break at all because i want
you to get how i would want my stuff
exactly i had you know one of my boys
helping me one time package it
and even then like okay you're packaging
i'm like but i'm watching you oh for
sure what i'm doing yep because of that
i'm like bro nobody's gonna give a [ __ ]
more about your product than yourself
it represents everything i used to get
tweezers on every hat and take out every
string and burn it with a lighter bro i
am
see you already know i'll do the lint
roller because i'm like brothers they
can't have you know like if they see
that [ __ ] they're gonna be like bro this
is everything that's the most important
part of the whole process because if i
got that like you couldn't put a little
effort into this yeah he doesn't really
give a [ __ ] thank you exactly you're on
the same [ __ ] you're on the same [ __ ]
but i just from a little bit if i do
whatever you're gonna do but from your
advice too i finally let go and delegate
it a little i haven't packed the order
in about five months
i went out the other day and didn't know
where something was like well
i love that like i don't know where
something's at that means this business
is running on its own [ __ ] yeah i got
time to do this and i open another spot
i announce that [ __ ] soon but i got
another warehouse so when my only advice
like you got your booking agent how much
easier is it now you got the booking
agent it feels good bro
i i'm trying yeah i'm trying to get to
the point that we're i mean i'm still
very hands-on i'm saying because you've
got a lot of you have to be you have to
be i guess
[ __ ] you know hopefully soon enough i
could get something else off my
shoulders exactly then you can start
focusing on the creative yeah just
was what's most important to me right
now inside the businesses business side
is uh balancing uh the family
like
time at home yeah because i'll be on the
road four or five days straight damn
yeah
so i'm like how am i going to make that
up now for me
so like
like i said anytime i'm not on the road
i'm with my daughter i got my daughter
with me she goes with me everywhere damn
near you feel me i could take her if i
could take her she's with me
or i'm with her
and um
so now i'm like i've been busy all last
week i was booked
um all
this week i'm booked yeah so now i'm
like
you know what i'm gonna do what am i
gonna do so [ __ ] we're going to
[ __ ] hawaii friday
oh that's with the oh that's the family
vacation that's a vacation i thought you
meant you have to be gone for a while
and then come back and do something nice
let me tell you guys why
uh
i never been so i'm [ __ ] excited
but uh
i'm still like let me get one day out of
the whole week for business let me shoot
a music video here yeah and drive come
here even if i'm in la for like four
days
i'm like i'm gonna book a studio session
video
i'm hon i'm going to pick up some
[ __ ] merch
wow my well i'm out here [ __ ] around
you're multi-business in right now yeah
yeah
yeah you're on the same you're an
entrepreneur and you're trying to and
you're perfectionist i see it yeah
perfection because all you should if
you're at your store that long yeah you
just because when you even when i go
check up i
fix this crooked shoes yep and then you
go hey man i need you to do a little bit
like this yeah i'm like hey if when you
get some time
fix this rack of clothes yeah and i know
you you're not like you know i need you
to do this [ __ ] it's like when you got
some time man can you clean this up yeah
and then and then after that if you can
uh mop that stain on the floor because i
wouldn't
i don't know i just don't like that yeah
you know what i'm saying a little [ __ ]
like they'd be like all right it's cool
you know
all right cool good job i'll be back
later sometimes i love it man that's so
sick so what's the exact address do you
have the address of the store yeah it's
uh 11 31 martin luther king jr way
so this is what i have i'm not saying
that's what's gonna happen but this is
what i would like for it to happen
uh like a year because we just opened in
may we've been open like two months
so
by sometime next year i want to relocate
hopefully to main street because it's
it's starting to get a lot more a lot
more people i thought
uh yeah the
the
cruise nights
oh yeah
yeah it's cool yeah
so i figure if we if we move to main
street uh
we'll probably get a different crowd and
it'll be bigger and plus a lot of people
don't like going to 12th street you know
we got to go there to get some shoes
[ __ ] that you know i mean
so
you know what i'm saying so i want to
replace this i'm parking right out front
leave the car on
[ __ ] leave it on it's not that bad
guys i'm sorry but you know what's right
press the brakes hold on to the brake
the entire time and when i'm gonna hop
in while you drive full throttle
you know now it's not that bad
so i want to [ __ ] move the business
to main street to hopefully get you know
yeah get that college crowd coming to
get [ __ ] supreme vans yeah [ __ ] like
that you know yeah so and then turn
whatever the building we got right there
turn into a barber shop because there's
no barber shops in the west
none
not one
he's really there's not one [ __ ]
barber shop in the west
there was one there was one
left an r i'll say by r by my grandma's
on six by mcdonald's it was a little one
though it was a little one but it was
there for forever right and then it
turned into a streetwear store yes yeah
yeah yeah they had the bar shop it had
the rotating thing now it's a smaller
grandpa used to go there so yeah now
it's a sam's smoke shop wow smoked
products yeah right next to mcdonald's
yeah right now i used to work there
every day so i'm like bro i'm gonna move
out go to main street and then turn this
into a barbecue that'd be great i can't
think of anywhere else you can get a
haircut and none of us would go there
that's the old man one yeah the old men
went to that one like my grandpa went
there like you got a job you go there
or the place on
martin or on uh what is it like and g
street
right there across the street from the
pig bbq pit oh yeah there's that hold on
yeah they have a bunch of like leonardo
dicaprio on the [ __ ] windows
like i don't look like that yeah they
have yeah give me the leo so i could
look like an [ __ ] yeah that's not
what i should have been there forever
are you seeing my haircut there i just
met the owner of the barbecue uh
yesterday morning how old is that
[ __ ]
okay so i thought he was
not just being you know like
old white man yeah it's not it's not a
young mexican dude oh he's he also that
he got it he bought it he must have
bought it because that's just been there
since before we were born yeah facts and
uh
so i just met him he's a cool dude
that's awesome
barbecue pig
you look pretty young i love that
he looked probably like mid-40s maybe
that's amazing dude and uh
yeah he owns yeah i met him yesterday
he's pretty dub because you ever been to
paul's place of course that's where
everybody over 80 years old and white
guys yeah everybody elderly goes to the
public and their their service and food
is fire it is public
so they [ __ ] uh you know how they
have the businesses on the tables
yeah inside the team
yeah so they're gonna do the same thing
so i was filling out a little paper to
put the business oh for for barbecue pit
and then i noticed he has the same
system we use at the shop the clover
system
so i was asking questions on how to use
it not necessarily use it but i'm like
trying to figure this [ __ ] out and he's
just like
i don't know he's like you know more
than me like you know
and i was just like all right you know
but he was a cool dude he was cool as
[ __ ] that's amazing i was like here's
you know you know i run a sneaker shop
here whatever he's like all my son's all
in the kicks office i'll be stopping by
type [ __ ] and that's how it usually
works you know what i'm saying business
to business word of mouth man word of
mouth just
mercedes not big
it's not big there's not a place not a
lot of places that actually make any
money
so
when they stay when they stay around for
a while they're there to stay but um
my question was oh my thing was paul's
place i actually asked one time i was
like you know what i'm about to put a
big push trees logo on all these tables
it is so expensive did you ask the price
at paul's place for the advertisement i
did
it's like [ __ ] 400 a month
[Music]
one of my friends uh my little sister's
like
graduation i went to dinner or some [ __ ]
or lunch and i saw him like i'm gonna
buy this she's gonna put all blowton on
this [ __ ] i'm gonna do some
blunt stuff but i yeah it's so expensive
so shout out to barbecue pit bro that's
crazy but what uh yeah
yeah that's i mean the owner was pretty
cool and then uh
yeah just just meeting other business
owners you guys gotta you know be in the
same place same time sometimes
and then they just ask you know like
where are you at like or what do you you
know run yeah and then they all end up
being cool people yeah you're in a whole
different bracket already i'm just from
reset and i'm looking at you and i'm
like so what's it like like you're in
the meeting with people because you know
there's
you barely make money you're poor and
holy [ __ ] you got a house that's all
there is merced there's no in-betweens
it's just that right there
so now that you're in the business
meeting you're in the city you're like
me looking at you like how is that [ __ ]
that's crazy to me i've never known
anybody that's been in this [ __ ] or
owned a store it's not necessarily like
a business meeting it's just like
sometimes you guys got to go
turn in papers for the city at the same
time
oh god you got you here like a little
network yeah small networking sparks
right right i got you yeah cause i only
paid tickets in those buildings and
stupid [ __ ] yeah and restitution that's
like there's nothing i can
relate to at this building except for i
know your mom works there like your
grandma works there that's it so it's
cool to hear that you're doing something
to where it's like yo i'm in these
buildings dropping paperwork off i love
that man you have a store yeah it's
foreign to me too you know it's not
something that i'm used to
but uh i'm learning it i'm getting used
to it [ __ ] yeah
um so real quick i mean i didn't even
ask or mention it yet how can everybody
go find anything you're doing like music
and then you said the shoes is on 11th
by buy right we already dropped the
address on that is there a website for
the store
no no we we're currently working on okay
okay yeah
yeah nah that's definitely needed
uh but like like fine are you on spot
like spotify i'm on uh you can find me
under gb on
most if not all major platforms just gb
just gb
uh youtube spotify apple music
um
my instagram is a ghetto boy.official
it's spelled g-e-t-t-o-b-y
dot
o-f-f-i-c-i-a-l official yeah and you
guys will put it somewhere or if you fit
me right here somewhere yeah yeah and uh
yes uh beside that you feel me i do have
like twitter and [ __ ] yeah i got twitter
but it's kind of hard
twitter's hard
to grow yeah not even that but like like
i got a twitter i got a tick tock
account like but
it's hard to find the time to hop on all
for sure
it takes 40 minutes sometimes close
consistently you know what i'm saying
and uh
yeah i i i haven't gotten social media
manager yeah i haven't yet that's next
that's next yeah no so and the next time
we see you like yo i got that social
media management post on tick tock right
like that's not even me i ain't doing it
yeah yeah no i i damn near found one for
uh for instagram
but now i need to like kind of conclude
it for all the platforms well hopefully
from this you've some
dude in college out there like that's
what i major in so and then i hear it
and there we go yeah take over my [ __ ]
well i mean i'm just happy to hear all
this [ __ ] man so everybody can go
support on any platform basically just
gb
yeah right and
for everyone out there i think the
fizzler cipher was [ __ ] sick as hell
i sent it to this school the other day i
think you did a great job bro i loved it
i loved seeing all this positivity come
from her shed sparked me to like yo how
can i do some more [ __ ] and help so
we'll talk more after this i would love
to help out however you can or however i
can that sounds cool
to get back to school [ __ ] because i
remember not having [ __ ] like i i
remember like
borrow pencil [ __ ] of everybody
yeah yeah you know
let me get some [ __ ] you always feel
stupid as [ __ ] walking in like i've got
a pencil today yeah i hate that [ __ ] so
i appreciate this and i love seeing it
so everybody go support if you're going
to buy some shoes go to the [ __ ]
store if you're going to listen to [ __ ]
maybe go listen to this right that's
that's all that's we can do is just
organic support hopefully our fans take
to it that's all we can do i love it and
and i appreciate you guys you feel me
having me on the show this is it's it's
a major
you know one of it was one of my major
goals in in my career in general you
feel me it is is it's crazy it's crazy
uh
you know mainly did it for the fans too
you know what i mean the the fans been
asking
tagging us
dm i mean
you should hop on doubles
yo i'm like i'm just i'm waiting on him
kind of you feel me waiting on the [ __ ]
to align itself exactly but it's it's
it's this does is
it's
it couldn't happen at a better moment
you feel me i believe but so and you
know
i appreciate you man grateful for that i
appreciate you being here i appreciate
you coming through driving this far just
to drive back and go work more i
appreciate it yeah i was gonna fly but i
was like not even there just taking the
time to come here and do this it's more
organic this is that and you heard that
it was early all right for every [ __ ]
guest that's ever been
drove from four hours away got you early
yeah come on and i'm late as [ __ ] to
everything oh are you but i wasn't gonna
be like oh
thank you man thank you so much
appreciate you man marty you got
anything else this is great i'm i just
i'm glad that when he said this was a
goal like this was a goal to be on the
show i love the fact that we're able to
even be that and just that it's just
we're able to have these conversations
and
and be able to shine a light on other
artists coming up and especially from
our hometowns and [ __ ]
i appreciate it man and [ __ ]
the one time i've been looking actually
like i want to do some more [ __ ] yeah i
feel it like i love that dude so i
appreciate you thank you for being here
please be safe get back home yeah and i
know you're going to go do your music
video do all your [ __ ] be safe when you
get there yeah do everything do your
thing i [ __ ] i love to see it man
appreciate it for everyone out there
thank you for being here marty thank you
guys thank you guys tb on all platforms
guys this has been the dope as usual
podcast i'm high as hell
i'm [ __ ] i don't know what was in
that
[ __ ] monster oh it was that joy it
was your joint
that [ __ ] got me high it was that black
cherry juice
cartel money cannabis yeah there she
goes money clothing appreciate it shout
out backpack boys five points
backpack boys that's the one i see you
[ __ ] with heavily it's the team
that's the team right there
uh
man a whole lot of stuff in the works
too you know what i'm saying um
everybody you feel me quality control
detroit
everybody we [ __ ] with you for me
it's just it's just in the circle man i
i love it i appreciate it
i think it was a [ __ ] monster
all right man thank you so much for
being here appreciate it this has been
the dope usual podcast i appreciate you
guys being here have a dope ass day
i noticed i was high as hell when i
almost lit this
yo great episode
[Music]